Debra Shapley when you think of Robert
McNamara what comes to mind the subject
of my book and of 20 to 30 private
interviews that we had in the course of
several years of my compiling the book
he was Secretary of Defense under
Kennedy and Johnson as many many
Americans know before that he had a long
career at the Ford Motor Company where
he rose to become president in 1960 and
then not as many Americans realize that
he was president of the World Bank for
13 years where he trooped around the
world and did a lot of very important
things which Americans being the way
they are tend to don't hear about or
have rather little curiosity about so
what comes to mind is an extraordinary
individual capable of great good and and
who created helped create the Vietnam
tragedy it's a very interesting pairing
of success and failure in this man why
did you want to do this oh I don't know
I had done a lot of defense writing as a
reporter for science magazine and as as
a freelance writer and I had done a lot
of reporting on arms control and I and I
came at it in a sense through the
mathematics analytic side I also came
very much to realize that my whole
generation the baby boomer generation
really were affected and scarred by
Vietnam they're 8.2 million people who
served in the armed forces between 1961
and 1975 and all of those people have
had some contact and some impact from
the Vietnam tragedy in our experience so
actually although I may have started out
of professional interest and rather
intellectual interest as I went on I got
very pulled in by the need to try to
understand this terrible riddle in our
past even Bill Clinton of course has
been it talked about Vietnam and Bill
Clinton's I think a year younger than I
am so I in a sense I'd got drawn in on
generational grounds I was reading The
Economist magazine the other day and
there was a column in there it said that
les Aspin was walking around with this
book tucked under his arm
the first question I had is how does
they how do they know that but did you
know that and why would he have this
under his arm well les aspin worked in
the defense department as a whiz kid for
mcnamara actually working in the army
between 66 and 68 I believe and he came
into the defense problem questioned the
great questions of national defense
through this same analytic route you
have to remember that mcnamara stood for
of quintessentially rational approach to
our defense policy and and he maintained
that through analytic techniques he was
going to find the objective answers of
thing what size force is best how much
is enough what is right for the nuclear
forces and I I like aspen Phil feel
inspired by this idea that maybe we can
have government that's a bet that
everybody agrees that there are certain
problems that can be solved rationally
Kennedy even said something like this
and I quote him in the book even Kennedy
said you know some problems are so
complicated we have to allow for experts
to work on them and wait till they tell
us what the answer is it sounds awfully
naive now but less I think is out of
this school strong Secretary of Defense
civilians making policy let's try to
figure out what is what are the best
answers I'm sure that Aspen like all of
us however is sobered by the fact that
it didn't work and that gets back to the
riddle of McNamara how could he be such
a remarkable analytic mind so
intellectual so curious and so so
wonderfully intentioned and be
associated with this tragedy where is he
today he's in Washington DC when he's
not in Aspen Colorado or parts other
parts of the world sitting on boards and
writing articles and he just had an
op-ed page in The New York Times on the
nuclear question advocating even lower
levels of nuclear weapons he's concerned
about population and saving the planet
really offshoots from his positions
taken his World Bank president which he
left more than ten years ago have you
talked to him since the book came out I
have not talked to him I've heard
indirect things obviously I hope to talk
to him and see where he
stands and how he feels about it what
are you hearing indirectly
well I can't repeat what I hear
indirectly I don't think that's quite
fair but I as I said to him in a final
meeting at I you know none of us sees
ourselves the way our biographer would I
don't expect him to agree with this book
certainly not in his entirety
I've tried to be very fair and Evan
Thomas in the Washington Post said I was
very fair to him and others have said so
too when was the first time he ever saw
him and when was the first time he ever
met him I only saw him when I first met
him I had not had any previous contact
and I think that was part of the early
intellectual phase of this project it
was curiosity about the subject rather
than a personal curiosity tweaked by
meeting him around Washington or meeting
him somewhere else
what year uh I think I met him in 84 or
late or 85 and did you start working on
the book that was when I started working
and I told him that I was going to do
the book anyway because there was such a
vast public record that a public policy
writers such as myself could write a
book even if he didn't cooperate many
people told me he would not never
cooperate because he is his record was
so complicated and so in a sense I flew
into it out of a sense of daring because
people said it was impossible to do
jumping all those fields and or getting
into nuclear arms and systems analysis
and international development and
building motorcars but that of course
was part of the interest of doing a
biography is that you can get involved
in the subjects indirectly through a
personality how many different times did
you sit and talk to him well I think
upwards of 20 I certainly on the
definitely upwards of 20 probably I
think 30 but I said more than 20 in the
book because I knew I was going to go
back for some more as I closed it out
and I didn't see the point in getting
tied into any one number of interviews
why did he see you in the first place I
don't know um maybe because I was luck
for Mars as a science writer and as a
public policy type with no previous
acquaintance
ship of him and well referenced and and
and capable of clearly capable of doing
a scholarly job I think he would not
have seen somebody who had had a track
record of attacking him in the press or
or somebody whom he he in sense already
knew he might have been more wary but in
a sense since I came to it cold and I I
also claim came to it saying I have an
open mind on this whole Vietnam thing
you know I don't buy thesis a or thesis
be your thesis C and I don't think a man
like that can help but being interested
in what someone from Mars might find
decide in the and people like McNamara
are very interested in in talking with
people who are going to who have an
interest in them
Kissinger you know didn't see his
biographer for a while and then got
drawn in and gave him a number of
interviews so it's sort of the same
curiosity I think that a figure of
public figure feels when they realize
someone's on their trail and going to be
interviewing all their old friends and
reading all these documents they sort of
want to know they want to get in on it
here and I like that part III McNamara
is very pleasant to deal with very
rigorous he's actually a very good
scholar for a guy who really had nothing
to do with history and never wants to
get into the past he has a one of
McNamara's traits as you see in the book
as a deep involvement with the present
let's march into the future the past is
behind
he's very American that way and I tried
in the sessions to educate him by
bringing in documents in one session
I'll never forget I brought in several
different books big books with footnotes
with accounts of the Berlin crisis and
pointed out in my cover letter the way
all none of these accounts agreed and
and but together they added up to a
cruddy record and he really got involved
in this and he said look this footnote
doesn't agree with this sentence and
distance this and he said you know how
can you call any of this history so I
was trying to show him a process in
MacNamaras fascinated by process
I want to read you two things in your
acknowledgement at the end of the book
you say he did not agree to speak on the
record about his role in Vietnam about
which he has maintained near complete
silence mm-hmm and then on the cover
Arthur Schlessinger says about your book
at last Robert McNamara speaks out on
Vietnam yeah and clarifies and explains
his role in the that tragic episode
which ones right he he his statements
that he released in the book he terms he
prefers to term clarifications I to get
him to release as much as he possibly
would and I think dr. Schlessinger
agrees that we that he's illuminating
his role in the conflict through the
quotes released I think he doesn't want
to say that he is now speaking on
Vietnam because he's afraid people come
at him and ask him more he's trying in a
sense it to have it both ways I think he
agreed with me that it was terribly
important for him to speak to my
generations and to start coming forward
I mean time is shortened and history is
urgent at his back oh and Bill Clinton
was advancing towards the White House
even as we finalized these quotes oh but
I he's a very complicated man and he
doesn't want to open himself up to
barrage of questions and everybody after
him about it I thought I think he's been
attacked he's been verbally insulted
over it III think he and he doesn't want
to face it I think completely you tell a
story about Jan scrubs yes would you
please repeat that well this is the
mcnamara ambivalence that I just was
alluding to Jan Scruggs took on all the
lions in this town to try to get a
Vietnam Veterans Memorial organized and
at the time the Jan Scruggs was trying
to get the building permits trying to
get congressional interest support he
called major figures associated with the
war and this was even before
my Linh designed controversial design
was agreed on he called back tomorrow at
the World Bank and said that he was
organizing the Vietnam Memorial and he
wanted to speak to mr. McNamara about
fundraising and McNamara came on the
line was very friendly and very helpful
and said sure I'll do everything I can
drop me a letter and call him get back
to me or drop me a letter and I'll get
back to you
Scruggs sent off a letter right away and
never heard another word from McNamara
and I still don't know why McNamara
distanced himself from the war memorial
effort but it was really shocking and an
outrageous in a way in my opinion to
ignore those guys they were being
attacked by some fellow Vietnam vets who
thought that it was a bad idea they were
being attacked by members of Congress
the buildings and monuments Commission
was giving them a hard time and and the
whole monument project was bringing up
terrible bitter divisions just as the
war did and and and McNamara dissents
has failed as a leader tremendously by
being unable to articulate where he's at
to those people and this was a prime
example did he ever go to the monument
he apparently has been privately uh
that's all I know
he certainly to my knowledge has never
been with anyone let it be known that
he's been there even George Bush walks
there from walk there from time to time
but he he's unwilling to really come to
terms with it still and I the quotes I
got from him I had to really work to get
he was born where Oakland California and
and just educated in the public schools
there came from very very modest
background in the book I stress the
absence of money in the household and
the extreme frugality and the and the
optimizing and the shopping and the
mathematical element of the housekeeping
which of course is true in many many
households but I think it's stamped
with this idea that he had to conserve
money and be frugal money was important
these are all American attitudes it's a
classic American story but it is also
sends a message to a boy to make money
because money is power money will get
you out of there to be frugal allocate
resources don't spend too much and all
of these things that came to be the
McNamara trade market defense he tried
to fight the war with a certain amount
of frugality not giving the military
everything they asked for and that was
an attitude stamped on him in childhood
where'd he go school he went to the
Oakland Public Schools and then to the
Piedmont high school and then to
Berkeley California graduating in 1937
so he was there during the Depression
and and he like many of the great civil
servants of our time had been great
public figures of our time was stamped
by the depression and the foe and the
political fears of the 30s with fascism
in Europe and Japan rising in Asia and
the and FDR's leadership which made a
deep impression on McNamara
I think FDR was one of his great heroes
did he serve in the military he entered
the Army Air Forces in oh I think 41 if
not late 1940 and taught at the Harvard
Business School where he was then a
teacher and they taught statistical
control to help control the logistics
and and munitions for all of the air war
which was being mounted in Europe and
Africa and the Pacific so he had a very
important role as Tex Thornton who was
ran that statistical control effort and
also went with him to Ford Motor Company
after the war where'd he meet his wife
he met her in Berkeley on at the campus
while they were both there and then he
fell in love with her later when he had
returned to home to work right after
business school and she was a charming
and wonderful person who in a sense had
all the qualities that he lacked she had
a lot of warmth a lot of ability to
sense where people were at
apologies to relate to them very quickly
and they were like two halves of one
coin their friends often say you talk
about her as it kind of a thread
throughout the entire book how come
because his her influence on him I think
as a balancing factor was was a
tremendous during his lifetime and she
died in 1981 and I think that was a very
big blow in fact I quote a friend in the
book is saying that our death is a
bigger blow to him than Vietnam because
she was such a force for balance and
stability and you know he's a very very
driven person and a lot of these people
who get as far as he does are they can't
contain their ambition and an aggression
and drive and you know make one thing
about back 12 if he were here he'd be in
constant movement he's very restless and
he when he gets impatient he starts
pulling his socks up he's he's hyper he
was a hyperactive type and she calmed
him down and had a very measuring
measure measure measuring effect on him
his kids how many three the girls both
born during the wartime years and the
son the only son born I think in 51 and
they were important and they were quite
a unified family I think during the four
years in Michigan after the war for
about 14 years but as I say in chapter 5
the move to Washington started to
separate the family from itself in the
sense that daddy became very important
and was not available the wife began
devoting much attention to him to
support his needs and then she had to
keep looking after the children who
turned out at several of them to have a
lot of difficulties particularly the boy
and I quote a scene in which the boy
remembers that because he had reading
difficulties his mom would sit with him
every night he was at Sidwell Friends
School and try to help him to read until
they would both cry and it's
to be a Washington wife and meet all
those obligations and spend hours with a
child trying to help him with his
reading year after year it's really was
clearly quite an a remarkable thing that
she did what's his relationship with his
son today and and he there were some
rough times that you read about well he
ran away he Craig McNamara is a very
personable boy had difficulty at st.
Paul's boarding school they didn't get
involved with a psychiatrist to help his
problems and then he got to Stanford and
began a serious anti-war career with
Professor Bruce Franklin whom some of
the viewers may remember was a leading
anti-war person and I think professor
Franklin had a lot of influence on Craig
and I say in the book I quote one of the
children's friends is saying that it was
like being a child of spear in that
Craig's group were really violently
anti-war and to be the son of the
perpetrator of the war was a very very
sort of schizophrenic position to be in
and and to the extent he already had
identity problems he says they were very
aggravated and he sent I have the story
that he told me he sent a note to he
called his dad's office that the
Secretary of Defense's office and asked
for information to explain the work as
he was sure his father wouldn't be
involved with anything bad like that we
and the office never sent the
information that would explain Vietnam
to Craig and that was part of his
Odyssey towards turning against the war
he ran away he ran away to South America
Easter Island when his mother visited
him in Eastern island she didn't know
he'd ever come back and he did come back
and there's been a slow reconciliation
where is he today and do they talk they
talk and I think they're really on the
best terms they ever have been the
mother talked to Craig and Lane yes and
he's a wonderful person and very
articulate oh he
they've Co invested in a walnut farm out
there and the father is an investor and
the boy has invested in it and he's
trying to make money off of farming
walnuts but isn't that the story a
generational story there where there's a
return to the land after this tremendous
spurt of rising father rising out of
near poverty and and reaching the height
being one of the highest-paid executives
in the world at Ford when you talk to
him
meanings former secretary McNamara for
this book where did you talk to him at
his office usually at 4:00 p.m. very
formal very controlled he McNamara
compartmentalizes his relationships with
people and if he knew you he might
remember you as the man who interviewed
him about his book he would then always
look at you and think book interview I I
know one person who lost an enormous
amount of weight and and the only person
in his life that never mentioned it was
Bob McNamara who thought of this man and
in the functional role and never even
made the observation about the change in
the prisons appearance so McNamara I
think wanted to come keep me
compartmentalized as this person who had
brought in documents and interviewed him
and was going to write the book and that
was fine did he ever get more friendly
as the 20 interviews went on well he was
friendly all along because we actually
found we could communicate quite well I
like being careful about what the record
shows I was careful trying to be careful
about what inferences I needed to know
about his motivations and why he did
things and he's so complicated and non
obvious in the way that he went about
things that if he hadn't explained
things a great deal of what's in this
book is told to some extent from his
point of view because if you're writing
somebody's biography you have to get in
their skin you have to imagine that
you're them now I don't think I have
that much in common with him but if you
hear somebody talk about themselves at
enough length you can then start
interpolating the motives beyond what
even literally they've told you and it
was a great help because he
I would get into situations where I had
evidence and I didn't know what the
answer was and then I would have to say
well now how would he respond to this
how is it most likely he looked at this
and with any luck I'd run in and ask him
but after a while you get a feeling for
somebody for the way that they're
responding to a situation and and so I
felt I could proceed with greater
confidence because of the sessions even
if they were formal how long was he at
Ford Motor 14 years how long was he
president only a few months from
November the first week in November
through the formal termination of his
employment which was January 20th 1961
so that was less a little over two
months how long was he Secretary of
Defense seven years how long was he at
the World Bank 13 years and what has he
been doing since the World Bank
experience and that year that he left
there was what 81 what's he been doing
the last 12 years well he has an office
a care of the Corning company because
he's on their board and he writes
speeches and gives them he's campaigned
very hard against Reagan's nuclear
build-up and against the Star Wars plan
he's working worked when the NATO
deployments he's worked on a lot of
nuclear issues he's avoided Vietnam like
the plague and then more recently into
population questions and he's given a
major speech on population as well as
going to South Africa actually these
advising the South Africans about how to
grow more democratic so he's become a
citizen of the planet you know singing
around on on and off airplanes
compulsive travel it's I compare him to
the Flying Dutchman because the Flying
Dutchman dared nature and the legend and
and was cursed by God for having tried
to sail around the Cape of Good Hope
against the storm and was cursed to sail
forever because he had been too bold and
there's a lot of hubris in McNamara and
and in a way all of this global travel
has such a restless air as though
there's no place he can come to rest
because he's still so controversial in
his own country I
won't say he doesn't have a home in the
United States because he's very well
respected by people in the arms control
community and the international banking
community but in a sense he doesn't have
a home I think until he comes to terms
with us you say that during the
interviews he often would tear up well
he's just I mean Bob McNamara is a very
emotional man that's what's so
interesting about the story and the
biography is that even in the early 60s
when he was projecting this image of
being a human computer and talking in
numbers rat-a-tat tat-tat-tat scott
staccato wallace i can I demonstrate in
Chapter five and six and seven the how
and twelve how emotionally driven he was
whether having first analyzed the facts
and coming to an analytic solution as he
as his ideology said or sometimes in
advance of it the tf-x was a wonderful
case of that he wanted a common plane
give me a common plane don't tell me it
can't be done
talk about the f-111 what is now the
f-111 so the tyrannous today
I think his age not having Margie around
and but it was always there the emotions
were always there why did you write
about his relationship with John Braden
and what what is it well Bob McNamara
has been seeing Joan Braden mainly I
think on their international travels she
travels with him a good deal and I as
far as I know that's still the case but
it picked up in sort of 82 roughly a
year after his wife died who is Joanie
she is a journalist and has worked in
public relations and other jobs she had
a job years ago for a Nelson Rockefeller
she was a friend of the Kennedys and one
of the original people in the Camelot
circle and and the wife of columnist Tom
Braden and so Joe Murray they're still
married and not neither of them disavow
the relationship they are there's a
triangle there there's Bob McNamara
traveling with mrs. Braden in their
friendship
there's no divorce in the Brayden
household they still live together and
she professes to be in love with both of
them so this is apparently a solution to
Bob McNamara's need for companionship
you write in your epilogue page 606 most
of the lessons drawn from McNamara's
life have been negative : the management
by numbers ruined America's
manufacturing know-how that the banks
lending left poorest countries with
crippling debt that the dis seats and
subterfuges of Vietnam disillusioned the
generation with government you want to
amplify on that and is it all negative I
think the book shows how much of it is
positive and I think the next sentence
goes on to discuss that there are much
positive there the next sentence is
David Halberstam
Omar's figure yeah because it has it is
his special skill to fool people to seem
better than his official acts whereas
the real McNamara is someone who says
one thing in public and always follows
the Mandate of his superior I tend
dispute I dispute the halberstam
accusation subsequently the most of the
lessons are negative I think the book
shows the positive legacy on nuclear
weapons which he did a great deal that
to build up our stockpile but it did a
great deal to control and stabilize I
think the book also shows a tremendous
positive legacy and defense management
and also at the World Bank where the
Green Revolution was spurred by McNamara
most of the lessons drawn that are
negative is in the American context
people don't like what he did on those
counts and and with some reason let me
read this line he wrote he is a pivotal
figure in the weakening and decline of
America despite the many virtues of the
American Century he embodies well you
know I wouldn't have had to write it
except that Vietnam itself was so
pivotal had he been had any of his
mistakes
been on a lesser scale for example there
were as I say in my later chapters there
were problems at the World Bank and in a
sense there were failures lurking which
he was embarking on they never came up
to hit him the way Vietnam did Vietnam
is almost in my opinion unique in its a
watershed event it's like World War one
for Great Britain and it's unique in the
case of our country and so I had to
write that sentence that way because it
Vietnam did weaken us both our morale
our economy our civic spirit our trusted
public institutions and it's the need
for that
assessment is driven by the scope of
that particular tragedy I also say I
believe it's in the prologue that many
who have done far less have been treated
kindly by history and that's very very
true he also write finally McNamara says
here for the first time publicly meaning
in this book that he and Kennedy plan to
withdraw all US advisors by the end of
1965
that's if he got reelected yes that's
correct even if the South Vietnamese
were going to be defeated he says I know
for a fact that John Kennedy would have
withdrawn from Vietnam and as you know
everybody debates this issue do you
believe him I don't believe him until he
comes up with evidence so I say I don't
believe him because he hasn't produced
any hard proof he he as I say at the end
of chapter 13 explained in the earlier
Vietnam sections he was the architect of
a plan to get the advisors out over a
phased period that they announced
October 1st 1963 all of the paperwork
first pulling out the advisors and again
it would take place presumably with
Kennedy's successful re-election was
based on military success in Robert
McNamara like John Kennedy left a public
record of announcements of success and
claims that we could leave because we
were going to be successful there was
even a qualifier in that announcement
that said that if we weren't successful
maybe we wouldn't and he used leaned on
that later when the troop buildup
occurred now what he is saying for the
first time in quotes that he released to
me is that what he and Kennedy really
intended was to pull out even if the
South Vietnamese were to be defeated
those are in quotes in the manuscript in
chapter 13 and repeated there at the end
of the book oh of course a lot of
Kennedy advisors claim this too because
X Kennedy advisors I think as I say in
the book I think they want to believe
John Kennedy would have handled this
thing more wisely than Lyndon Johnson
did I think it's very subjective and we
really need something hard so at the
moment I don't believe him back in in
those years what were you doing I was
attending Radcliffe College and
graduated in 67 and it was the year my
fall of my senior year that McNamara was
attacked as he was leaving Quincy House
and had to get up on the car and shout
do you remember that Bryan and he had to
get up on the car in fact I think I have
a picture of it did I not in the book
and of course that was one of the very
first East Coast protests Berkeley had
already erupted Berkeley being Berkeley
but in those days it was not done that
students protested I was not there I was
not an anti-war person at all on the
contrary I was I think more patriotic
than more more willing to hear the case
for fighting than many of my Harvard
colleagues but that little demonstration
made a great impact at the time and if
rereading the old issues at the Harvard
Crimson I saw that the students were
required by the Dean to apologize to mr.
McNamara the next day so that just shows
you that the fall of 1966 was sort of
the beginning of a cusp which really the
60s as in the anti-war sense really
didn't erupt until 67 68 it sort of
started in 66 and became and after that
I worked for the Quincy Patriot Ledger
as a reporter and nobody Quincy Quincy
mass Massachusetts Quincy you had
Wednesday except where you're from no no
and then for the MIT Technology Review
so I I went straight from college into
journalism and covered the anti-war
movement actually up there in Cambridge
and I felt very well placed as a
journalist I felt no temptation to
demonstrate I I was not where Bill
Clinton was at I was worried about my
country and I was worried about
government but I was not even doing what
Bill Clinton was doing I was sitting
there puzzling about it and when the
whole Clinton service thing broke story
broke as I was closing at my book I
realized that I I'm I'm quite sure I
would have served and if I had served I
would have tried to figure out how to go
Chris being a girl it was a non-issue
where were you born
Washington DC and doctors hospital and
what 1945 what did your parents do
my father was associate deputy
administrator of the NASA and involved
with Apollo program and involved with a
budget bureau and actually was there
then the room when McNamara learned
Kennedy was shot because the budget
bureau was reviewing the the defense
budget and over at McNamara's office and
there's any people my tours of your one
of one of several Mack Bundy and Roz
gilpatrick there are many accounts that
all converge there in chapter 14 but I
think you'll see daddy listed in the
footnote as one of the sources the no I
mean many people in my family are
scientists and I come as I told you I
come actus from a lot of intellectual
distance and and I got drawn in and I'll
tell you something else about where I
came I told you that during the campaign
it it the Clinton letter to the Arkansas
guy made me rethink where what I would
have done and I feel very clear that I
would have served and no question I
certainly would not have gone into the
anti-war cap I felt very comfortable as
a journalist observing these things
without having to take a position but
the story of McNamara at the World Bank
is the story of a man deeply activist
in wanting to help
all these crises and conundrums in
third-world countries
and he made a very good point in a
speech in during the 80s dirt when there
was a big famine a Somali like situation
and he said you know these images of
hunger are only a partial part of the
story we in international agencies have
got to slog year in year out famine or
no famine to try to solve issues to help
these societies learn to live with
themselves we see that in Bosnia today
and we see that yeah and I suddenly
realized that what I was writing in the
World Bank chapters the four chapters in
this biography devoted to this highly
active individual with all this
financial technical means at his
disposal is that of an activist who
wants to intervene who wants to play who
believes he can make these governments
come together and solve their crises and
now Clinton of course is is plight
saying the same sort of thing
so in a sense the moral became how would
my generation now lead I started the
book looking back at our past troubles
and now I realize it's almost
prescriptive for the future here's how
McNamara one of our role models reacted
to turmoil in the third world now what
do we do when you look back to Vietnam
do you point a finger at John Kennedy or
Lyndon Johnson or Robert McNamara and
say but we wouldn't have had this if
they didn't do it did it oh the drift
most people take the halberstam
indictment as well as the way the New
York Times interpreted the Pentagon
Papers to mean that a group of bad guys
with bad character caused it and if we
hadn't had those guys we would have had
not had the tragedy most recent
scholarship and I think it's not for me
to say but I would say my book supports
this says the world view for intervening
to stop Communist China was so strong
that almost almost anyone that you might
have had in high positions might have
done this
same thing I do however fault McNamara
for lack of a political sense as I say
in chapter 15 and 16 because it really
was up to the Kennedy advisors to tell
Johnson hey maybe you really don't want
to do this Kennedy's legacy does not
require you to stay there and he didn't
have the courage he was not really a
leader I call that section of the book
the test because he was being tested in
terms of his own political judgment and
he failed did Lyndon Johnson fire Robert
McNamara he yes in effect why because
Robert McNamara was becoming a liability
because he was becoming very emotional
and very out of out of sync with the
other advisors the in 1967 the Johnson
administration you may remember was dug
in
it was the wagons were drawn and Walt
Rostow and Dean Rusk and Lyndon Johnson
himself were shooting through the wagons
out of the Indians out there including
the media and everybody else if you read
the minutes of the Tuesday lunch minutes
of those Tuesday lunches some of which
I've quoted here you had feel this sense
of entrapment which of course we know
later white houses and leaders
presidents became victim to to its ass
White House syndrome and McNamara
meanwhile was becoming progressively
more open in his wish to stop the
bombing and on November 1st 1967 as I
say in chapter 19 he laid on the
president a memorandum saying
recommending a bombing halt saying he
thought it would lead to negotiations
with the north and that that was the
course to follow and and recommending a
whole bunch of things that were so far
out of line with what the advisors
circle wanted the Johnson at that moment
picked up the phone and told the
executive directors of the World Bank to
start moving with Treasury to start move
with McNamara's move out and to the
World Bank so the World Bank was in a
sense all not dumped but laid on him not
against his will he was interested in it
as a sort of possible possibility but he
went out of his way to create no record
that he would wanted it out because if
word that he wanted out
were to get out then the Washington
media would have a heyday you know
McNamara seeks to leave office so they
played a game with each other and in
chapter 19 I show Johnson not telling
McNamara not McNamara not wanting to say
anything open a Johnson I mean as I say
to the two close men that were
cheek-by-jowl day after day month after
month year after year unable to talk to
each other about the major thing that
was going to divide them
you've got endorsements on the back from
Stanley Karnow George and guy Ronald
Specter Douglas Pike Arthur Schlessinger
jr. and Dan Rather any reason for that
group did you get those endorsements
yeah I got some of them and the
publisher got some of them but they were
all and we have several others actually
that weren't there it was just the what
was the reason for them the reason was
that I think these people realized they
saw the manuscript and they realized
that I had done ask Ollie a job as I
could and that the book is a sort of
chips where they Mabel in terms of
McNamara doing great things on some
fronts and as you saw some rather harsh
judgments about his overall role because
of the pivot miss Vienna the one I would
be most interested in is the Arthur
Schlessinger endorsement is this an
endorsement of this whole book or just
what he says you're about what of what
McNamara says about Vietnam yes let me
read it again in case somebody joined in
the conversation had last Robert
McNamara speaks out on Vietnam and
clarifies and explains his role in that
tragic episode yes but dr. Schlessinger
was very helpful to me all along during
the project and shared his diary entries
with me and knew my previous work and he
had in fact had and many others had been
encouraging of my scholarship effort is
by no means his endorsement of my
conclusions he but he was very glad that
his friend Bob was ready to speak out
and finally able to come forward and and
I think that was the right position for
him to take why won't he speak out and
why won't any more than you've been able
to get him to speak here and why won't
he write a memoir meeting Robert
McNamara yes well as I said at the
beginning of
our session Brian my reading is that
Robert McNamara is still running from it
I also think that it's quite convenient
to keep talking about population and
nuclear weapons and other issues where
he is quite well-respected and doesn't
have the same kind of tomahawks out
there waiting for him whereas if he were
to talk about Vietnam he there was a
tremendous amount of personal flak that
he would take I think that's something
he should do and I've told him that over
and over and that was the reason one
reason I got to the point of releasing
these quotes and one of the most
important things that he says I don't
even know if he understands how
important it is is that in my book in
chapter 17 and again in chapter 19 he
says why it was useful for them to go on
fighting even if he knew it was
militarily unwinnable that's a point
Brian that we should dwell on for one
minute if we could many of those
veterans of that era despised McNamara
for having said in the Westmoreland
trial in 1984 and and also earlier when
the Pentagon Papers were published for
urging them to fight a war that he knew
was militarily unwinnable if he had this
great insight why did he go on in public
telling us to fight and why did he make
all these upbeat statements now what I
show in chapters 17 and 19 was that he
was playing a kind of semantic game with
his public statements and in the later
warriors he was saying the Chiefs and
general Westmoreland think we're winning
and the military picture looks good
according to all military professionals
he kept using language like that the
fine print is he wasn't saying he said
that now you know this is like a Hall of
Mirrors here now what he says in my book
is I wanted them to fight on in the
field because the professionals thought
we were getting somewhere I want
to put pressure on Hanoi by causing all
this loss to their side to get them to
come to negotiate on the political track
he kept saying we had two tracks and
he's absolutely right he was pushing
much harder than any other high official
the administration to get negotiations
he wanted to stop the bombing he had all
these radical positions so in a sense
what I show in Chapter seventeen and
nineteen is that he had a position which
he doesn't defend but he does explain
which was why it was useful to fight in
order to put pressure on the enemy so
that we could get a settlement soon and
I believe as I say in the epilogue that
one reason he carries around so much
guilt about this is that he still thinks
he could have brought it off and he
regrets not having contained the war
before Johnson eased him out in November
of 1967 well you know I this is not a
nun discussable position I mean he's a
very articulate man if he were wanted to
give a speech about this and really
explain it in depth instead of doing it
only through me uh he could come forward
and it angers me that he doesn't I hope
he will I hope he will maybe look at my
book as a stepping stone towards being
able to come to terms with this thing
because it's it wasn't wicked or
horrible on his part it was the the
finagling of a high official who thinks
he can pull the levers and make it all
work out and get Hanoi to negotiate that
may be defensible and maybe not but it
is an explanation that he owes us did he
or his Pentagon ally to us during the
time that he was there for those seven
years oh yeah oh yeah there's no
question about it on purpose yeah a lot
of it I think is sort of tactical I mean
the most obvious example that I give is
in the most easily Documenta bULOG
sample is when he said right away he
found there was no missile gap and the
reporters went out and printed this on a
background not attributing it to him by
name then it came out that he had said
it this was right when he took office in
February of 61 and then when Kennedy
knew that it was McNamara who had said
there was no missile gap
they of course had run on the platform
that there was a missile gap he then
starts saying he hadn't said it and
there was a lot of backpedaling and yes
that's a lie because he had said
something like that to the reporters and
yes it's politically convenient to deny
it to avoid embarrassing the president
we've seen a lot worse since in other
precedents and at some point someone
should look back and compare this with
the with the later record I think his
his critics would say that he and
Johnson set a new low in this regard and
degraded the standards of office Kennedy
also wasn't too truthful about certain
aspects of Vietnam so yes I find that he
lies it and he and he likes to maneuver
his position on things and sometimes
seem one way to people and seem another
way other people there's a lot of
manipulation but I don't think it's
wicked I think it's done out of passion
it's out of a will to make situations
work out the way he wants to make them
at work at it you've in the
acknowledgments you've got a number of
institutions I just want to ask you what
role they play in all this yeah
particular thanks go to the Center for
Strategic and International Studies yes
yes what's that that was at the time
associated with Georgetown University
it's a think-tank down on 18th and Kay
and they gave me an office and with no
as I say there are no strings attached
no review over my project content or the
manuscript and they often house authors
and and scholars doing different things
do they have a point of view they have a
point of view well I don't know that
they have any point they have no point
of you on this book they never saw it
before publication and I certainly
submitted to them not one whit of paper
saying what it would say or what it
wasn't say they support they gave me
this office in the first two years of
the project and many many people will
attest that I didn't know what this book
was going to say at that time I was
studying into the research myself who
supports them and what kind of a view
that people when you say the Center for
Strategic and International Studies does
it have a political slant to it well
it's run by Dave Abshire who was an
appointee I believe in the he was
ambassador of NATO in the Reagan years I
and it's the Abshire was it CSS went to
a Regan appointment and it came back and
they have a lot of retired military
people there I don't think they have any
real one point of view but Alfred P
sloan Foundation the sloan Foundation
sponsored the management side of
McNamara they gave me a little a little
bit of help with my early management
work Alfred P Sloan you as you probably
know overhauled General Motors made a
huge fortune and as my book explains in
when McNamara and these young guys left
the Army Air Force were looking for some
place to try their skills they got to
Ford and they were going to make it over
an image of Sloan and GM so actually
Alfred Sloan not only Foundation sported
book but his management has discussed
directly he's like a character and what
did they do for you in this project they
gave me a little financial support two
occasions they have a point of view you
know the John D and Catherine T
MacArthur Foundation know they that is a
program that has no point of view it's a
program for peace and security writing
and it gives grants to individual
authors and there they look for authors
doing unusual things and one of the
things I will say about this from a
biographical standpoint scholars get
quite upset sometimes with journalists
doing biographies we're doing these
major books and as you well know there's
this whole trend in publishing to have
journalists and reporters taking on
these great big subjects bob woodward
takes on the supreme court so on and one
has to ask oneself why the academic
community is does not as is not leaping
into this void and and why an academic
for example would not do a biography of
mcnamara the answer is I know from
academics who have considered it and
discussed the I think the quick answer
is that our academic success tracts are
so disciplinary that a book about Ford
nuclear Vietnam Len
would would could cost an academic
points because that all these different
disciplines would compete with each
other or he'd be blurring it his or her
specialty and I think it's really
something that Brian that you and your
readers your viewers should think about
that x2 well the the proper contribution
that our scholars should be making to
all of this I'm a scholar in the sense
that I did my two earlier books were
published by the ISI press which is a
scholarly present Philadelphia and the
Johns Hopkins University Press and I
have been through the whole
fact-checking academic procedure and
MacArthur and Sloan supported me because
of my scholarly background so I'm more
scholarly than most journalists and I
tried to be very scholarly with my notes
and fact-checking here but I really
think that a lot of our university
professors should be thinking about why
it is the journalists are leaping in to
do this there's an obvious need for a
book on McNamara MacArthur this was a
digression because you asked me about
MacArthur that MacArthur program gives
grants to individual writers without an
institutional affiliation even and they
prefer things that are
cross-disciplinary and daring that the
normal academic treadmill won't produce
what have people been telling you to
your face about this book as you travel
about um oddly enough most of the
interviewers on the shows are people who
remember the era and say Oh Bob McNamara
we remember him there was one
interviewer who said folks go in the
bookstore look at these eyes from
looking at you from the cover don't you
remember that focus in intensity and it
was it was sort of neat because and one
doesn't have to spend half an hour
explaining who McNamara was they've been
telling me that it's an ambitious book
and that they like it anybody upset with
you from you know the the folks that
were big john kennedy or london johnson
supporters
oh well I think I get a little bit of
feedback from people who were close to
the Kennedy crowd that whom I won't name
because it's a little diffuse in any
event that this book is too harsh on
McNamara and so you read a sentence
about he being a pivotal figure in the
decline of the American Century whose
virtues he embodies but I think that's
inevitable because I think people the
group of people who knew Kennedy and who
were close to him have a tremendous
fondness for each other and they've been
through a lot of pain and and they've
watched Kennedy's reputation be torn to
shreds in book after book after book and
I'm sure that in an ideal world they
would love to see McNamara totally
rehabilitated and I just can't do that
with any credibility which fact that you
uncover in this book he thinks the most
relevant for new information oh I think
at the risk of being obsessed with
Vietnam I think the most important
revelation is McNamara's development of
his own position about why he stayed on
and fought if if there was a valid
military reason for continuing the
fighting that's something that many many
veterans need to know and their families
what's next for you I don't know I I
really would like to write something
short and focused and the doesn't leap
inbounds almost like an etude in music
I'd like to work on my skills my
narrative skills and find some short you
can suggest one Brian well before we get
I have no suggestion for a except I want
to read your your dedication and to the
millions Long's dedication I've ever
seen
to the millions who like me were born as
World War two ended and the Cold War
began and whose lives were changed by
this one life why such a long dedication
well I didn't know how else to say it uh
I felt that was written during the
campaign actually and as Clinton and
gore were moving
forward further and further and all of a
sudden my generation was under scrutiny
and the question of what we had written
what what we had learned and what we
would do and whether we were capable of
being grownups so I I suddenly realized
that that my interest that the way to
kid the appropriate way to cast my
interest in the subject was generational
if there was one chapter you'd want the
new government to read that you think
would have the most impact positive
impact from what you've learned oh wow
um wow that's hard to say or one
particular would it be the Vietnam story
the worldbank story the Ford Motor story
I almost think the Bank story on the
epilogue I think they fit together as a
story of a top-down manager trying to
make everything happen and it shows both
the hubris and also the compassion and
the capacity to do good which is big
part of what McNamara was all about this
book is written by or was written by
Deborah Shepley this is what the cover
looks like the title of it is promising
power the life and times of Robert
McNamara published by Little Brown thank
you very much well thank you Brian it
was a pleasure